I am black I am black I am black I am
black I'm black I am black I'm Asian how
many inches everybody have in your hair
right now girl one week new is 24 inches
bam thank you for asking I have uh 22 uh
18 and 16 inches of my hair stolen right
now I'm big wig style girl I have not I
have a natural haircut I have a face I'm
natural so I'm waiting for braid season
I shaved my hair so I have like a blonde
little you know go with the Tiffany how
to shoot right now that's right I don't
have a wig on or I don't have any type
of weave so that's gonna make me feel a
little suspicious from the start which
I'll moisturize with this morning well
you know what are you talking about skin
or hair oh you went to skin yeah yeah
yeah okay shea butter peanut butter
definitely shea butter I'm real dry so I
had to use real thick lotion oh I'm
sorry I use that shade like that big
stuff once you get off the shower you
put this butter a little oil who just
said shea butter at the end well I said
shea butter with the oil when you get
off the shower no listen I don't play
that we cannot be ashy okay how you make
your how do you make collard greens ham
hocks you need smoked meat smoked turkey
tails small turkey tail it was very
intimidating too I will say because they
came with the heavy questions like right
off the bat they were ready
um I'm Caribbean so we don't really eat
collard greens I'm from Haiti so we
don't eat that so I don't really cook
I'm not gonna lie yeah okay if you're
going to Trader Joe's I'm sorry how long
y'all cook your greens for until the
Lord says stop
what shows didn't people watch growing
up
girl
yeah
my time kind of yeah it's uh what's her
name there we go thank you yeah
where's everybody from I'm from North
Carolina I'm From The Far East side of
Indy Indy Indiana Oh okay specifically
because it's Indiana then you've got
Indianapolis I'm in the heart of the
Season yeah okay I'm from Jackson
Mississippi oh yeah yeah oh
foreign
Riverside California my mom and dad
separated so he lived in Chicago Gary
Indiana so I was kind of like from the G
yes
Gary Indiana so we know
yeah yeah I'm from Eugene Oregon and
then I moved out here like two years ago
I lived between Detroit and Battle Creek
Michigan
I'm from Jersey 20 minutes out of the
city who's from Oregon kid dust me can I
hear your customer service voice oh my
God
Hi how are you doing today oh my gosh
like I don't know I don't have a
customer service voice like that I have
a customer service voice how many black
people from Oregon two percent yeah
that's that's a baby suspicious and also
what was it about Cadets her code switch
so I was like okay let me see if Cadets
just has one of those voices or if this
is a white woman is anyone else here
have like African family members or
immigrant family members my family
they're immigrants yes I was I'm a slave
black person my dad he is an Ethiopian
Refugee and moved here when he was a
teenager so yeah raised in that culture
and then my mom is white so I'm biracial
okay uh what school did everybody go to
for what age like college I went to a
pwi I also went I went to Michigan State
he also went to PW pwi I went to Jackson
State I don't want to give them credit I
went to Indiana University
what's everybody's
um favorite like icon growing up bro I
want to say mine was like Chaka Khan
I've seen her a couple of times
okay her too I didn't really look up to
celebrities growing up I'm honestly it
sounds cliche about my mom because she
was a widow and she raised me and my
sister by herself so I look up to her
still yeah that's beautiful mine's
probably Shirley Chisholm the politician
oh hey I'm cool I directed this
episode of odd one out if you like this
episode and you want to see more
subscribe to our Channel
okay
[Laughter]
so the tie is between EJ say hello hello
Michelle say hello hello and tia say
hello hello four of you who are not
called out each of you can ask them one
question okay
um maybe how has your relationship with
Blackness changed like over the course
of your life I mean I'm me I love me
like period it's just it's getting
bigger better and better every day I
love being black I would not choose it
any other way I grew up with a family
that was really proud to be black but I
grew up in a really white neighborhood a
really white area so I didn't see people
who looked like me and that was really
difficult to deal with because people
just made me feel bad for being like a
dark-skinned black woman especially it
wasn't until I went to college and met
other black people that I really got a
chance to be proud of my blackness and
get involved with the community and I
just love myself more and more every day
honestly
she started talking about her experience
as a dark-skinned woman and I was like
for somebody now I'm black to be company
here specifically being like Oh I'm a
dark-skinned woman I'm like ah that
would be sick so I was like EJ was
telling the truth I was gonna say yeah
just growing up and just being kind of
uncomfortable in my skin but then like
being able to go like I went to
predominantly white school sometimes and
mixed but then when I went to Jackson
State just being able to be proud of
like who I am and accept who I am more
but now kind of the way things are with
the time it's just
I think more people are open to learning
more and understanding and being more
accepting so
um it's just good to have those kind of
conversations to bring more awareness
all right
say anything about her Blackness and
like finding her Blackness she was just
like I found myself so I found that to
be a little suspicious
[Music]
I just kind of kept it General to my
experiences with black culture and how I
grew up but they were coming straight
with the I think the first round was
supposed to be very light it was not oh
I don't know I don't know I feel like I
don't know I really believe y'all the
girl what's your name from Oregon Cadets
Cadets yeah you adopted no I'm not she
said yeah like yeah and I believe that
she said my name is literally yeah yeah
she said I feel like the fact that my
name is cadesque was kind of carrying it
a little I don't know any white people
who would have an Ethiopian name I
always want to hear everybody's customer
service voice I'm just trying to hear
the switch okay hi how are you hey hi my
name's Kia how can I help you today good
afternoon thank you for calling Quicken
Loans hi my name is EJ how can I help
you today
do it okay I'm ready I'm ready okay
[Music]
okay wait okay hi my name is Adrian how
y'all doing today is it good I'm gonna
be like hey girl what's good
for me I'm over time one more time one
more time hi thanks for calling better
that was good thank you whatever you're
selling I'm buying thank you what is
your favorite thing about being a black
woman oh all of it
um I love the fact that I know I won't
crack
I was just looking to mirror myself
you know I'm fine as hell I love the way
I sound I love the music I love the
culture I love yeah I love it like I can
change up my hair if I want to fro if I
want some straight hair I want braids I
don't crack the show like we we're lit
what's popular in fashion right now and
beauty trends are very much because of
us because a black woman and yeah yeah I
can answer my own question though I feel
like
okay just like Malcolm X said we are the
most disrespected
people in this country and we are black
and we are women we have two things
against us and we just have to wake up
every day resilient as
right and then are we gonna say sorry oh
no it's okay I I just wanted to like on
the side of that question what's
something that you guys find is like a
struggle you face every day as being a
black woman I mean I hate it because
social media is the way that it is yeah
but it's like you get on Twitter and you
can't go on there without Amanda grading
like black women like just for like what
like it's just like why are you on here
preaching so much hate like your mother
is a black woman why are you talking
about the craziest thing what I had to
do with being a black woman especially
in Corporate America
yeah it's very hard because we are
supposed to be seen as strong we are 17
as like I remember my last job they were
like well Candace you know she's gonna
tell it how it is she's gonna do this
she's gonna do that unlike Candice's
like I'm a black woman but you know I
could be soft too like I don't have to
be so direct yeah I'll like want to
speak up about something but then I also
don't want people to like think of me in
a certain way like it's like a
stereotype so then I'll like silence
myself and it's just like a perpetuating
like cycle yeah what's your mama's names
Connie well yeah Connie Connie yeah Lily
it was Constance but they changed it to
Connie if it helps my big mama's name is
Mosey
yeah my big mama
my grandma named Margaret speaking of
big mama yes who played Big Mama
all right I just had I just want to make
sure all right there's a question
so once again there was not a majority
but there was only a two-way tie this
time EJ and Cadets
okay either one of y'all when you were
getting your hair pressed what
precautions did you have to take like
what were you told to do hold my ear
why is that my turn to answer oh sorry
okay my mom she's white so honestly my
hair Journey kind of questionable Water
Conditioner but um when I would
straighten my hair it would literally
just be like a heat protectant spray but
I honestly like never straighten my hair
like I always wear it curly or like in
braids see I grew up with like a perm
from a young age washing it in the sink
and my job was to hold my ear and when
my mom would pull my head back I need to
stop moving because it was my fault so
EJ's voice
um isn't like stereotypically like
probably what you would think of when
you think of a black woman something
that could be kind of a red flag but in
this game you never know what type hair
do y'all have 4C and 4A 3B how many
times do you wash your hair how many
times you wash your hair period a week
every two weeks three times three times
well she probably has different hairs
yeah I have three beads are you gonna
draw that scalp out but I don't use
shampoo every time oh yeah yeah mostly I
just keep it in braids what kind of
braids either flat twist or I'm gonna do
I can't cornrows so I do uh french
braids my mom never talked she can't do
hair sadly bless her I don't want to
vote forever okay y'all I swear I'm
black
because that's had a point where she was
like no I promise you I am black and I
was like that's exactly what a white
woman was he uh
we actually just went to Popeyes and I
ordered food and the girl pulled down
the thing she was like I'm not gonna lie
I I thought you were a white person I
was like that's okay when people hear me
they kind of cast me kind of to the side
of thinking like maybe she's like an
Oreo or something like that which is not
the case if you think that the mole is
still in the box and you want to
continue playing raise your hand on
three okay one two three
if the Box turns green you guys have
successfully voted them all out if the
Box turns red that means you guys have
lost and the mole has won yeah
and the box turned green
I knew you were black everyone can take
their blindfolds off I'm gonna count the
three not yet okay okay I'm deciding
five two three
oh baby
[Laughter]
well she said turkey I was like yeah
so I was adopted I was born in Korea I
was adopted by a black family in the
Army yeah so I grew up in Jackson
Mississippi I went to Jackson State so
I'm heavily influenced by Black Culture
uh but I know it was a little hard
because I don't like to misrepresent
myself either like I picked up on it
yeah there were some things where I was
like yeah I'm not going to speak in
first person like me as a black woman
because you ain't black but you got nice
ass teas
yeah if I would have been here when you
said what's your mom's name my mom's
name is Ernestine I would have probably
won
Ernestine yeah you should have said that
oh my golly damn y'all fine
okay somebody said that they were going
to bump me out earlier because they're
like I don't know you just seem too
black I was like thank you too black I
had a lot of fun I came here to win and
that's exactly what I did I was like wow
I could hang out with Michelle like I'm
sure we have so many common growing up
experiences even though I my family's
black and a lot of my friends are black
I don't know what it's like to walk in a
black woman's shoes everybody's not
monolithic so it was interesting hearing
everybody's responses and how they were
different I was one of the few women of
color in my high school and in my city
like in the past I felt like a bit of an
outsider because of that but now I've
been able to just embrace the fact that
like basically there are just many
different ways of being black yeah
[Applause]
oh
my God
[Music]